Y
. CNN'S MANU RAJU WAS KEEPING
TRACK OF IT ALL FROM CAPITOL
HILL. IT DIDN'T TAKE LONG FOR
HOUSE GOP LEADERS TO RUSH TO
DONALD TRUMP'S DEFENSE SAID FROM
DAY ONE. THIS IS A POLITICAL
STUNT ATTACKING MANHATTAN
DISTRICT ATTORNEY ALVIN BRAGG
OVER THE UNPRECEDENTED
INDICTMENT OF A FORMER PRESIDENT
AND CRIMINAL CHARGES. ZERO TRUST
THAT THIS WILL PLAY OUT FAIRLY
TODAY. BRAGS OFFICE PUSHING BACK
IN A SCATHING LETTER TO THREE
HOUSE GOP CHAIRMAN WHO HAVE
SOUGHT HIS TESTIMONY IN INTERNAL
RECORDS, ACCUSING THEM OF DOING
TRUMP'S BIDDING AND WRITING. AS
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN. YOU COULD
USE THE STATURE OF YOUR OFFICE
TO DENOUNCE HIS ATTACKS URGE
RESPECT FOR THE FAIRNESS OF OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND FOR THE WORK
OF THE IMPARTIAL GRAND JURY, BUT
HOUSE SPEAKER KEVIN MCCARTHY
SAYS THAT BRAGG WILL BE HELD TO
ACCOUNT SOURCES SAY. TRUMP IS
EXPECTED TO BE ACCUSED OF
FALSIFYING BUSINESS RECORDS TO
COVER UP 2016 PAYMENTS TO ADULT
FILM ACTRESS STORMY DANIELS TO
KEEP QUIET ALLEGATIONS OF AN
EXTRAMARITAL AFFAIR, BUT NO ONE
HAS SEEN THE EVIDENCE
PROSECUTORS HAVE UNCOVERED
PRESIDENT THAT DIDN'T STOP ONE
CONGRESSMAN TO CLAIM THE
PROSECUTOR COULD HAVE INDICTED
THE HAND SANDWICHES HE WAS
HANDING OUT ON CAPITOL HILL TO
SPOT A PILE OF GARBAGE. AND THIS
THING LOOKS LIKE A PILE OF
GARBAGE. EVEN WITHOUT SEEING THE
EVIDENCE. YOU'RE CERTAINLY IS
INNOCENT. I'M NOT CERTAIN OF
ANYTHING. EXCEPT THIS. THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME IN THE HISTORY OF
THE COUNTRY WE'VE INDICTED
PRESIDENT AND THE FACT THAT YOU
KNOW HE'S JUST NOW ANNOUNCED AND
THEY ROLLED THIS THING OUT. IT
SMELLS PRETTY FISHY. REPUBLICANS
AGREE DESPITE NOT SEEING THE
CHARGES. AREN'T YOU JUMPING TO
CONCLUSIONS? I MEAN, HE MIGHT
HAVE BROKEN THE LAW. IS THAT
CONCERN YOU? WE DON'T THINK WE
DON'T THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP
BROKE THE LAW AT ALL, BUT THERE
HAS BEEN SILENCED FROM SENATE
GOP LEADER MITCH MCCONNELL AND
HIS NUMBER TWO JOHN THUNE, WHO
TOLD CNN EARLIER THERE WERE
LEGITIMATE QUESTIONS ABOUT BRAD
. HE WOULD NOT ALIGN HIMSELF
WITH HOUSE GOP EFFORTS. THE
SUPPORT HOUSE REPUBLICAN EFFORTS
TO CALL ALVIN BRAGG UP HERE AND
GET HIM TO TESTIFY. I'M NOT
GONNA GET INTO WHAT THE HOUSE IS
DOING THERE. TWO OTHER MEMBERS
OF SENATOR MCCONNELL'S
LEADERSHIP TEAM DID COME OUT AND
CRITICIZE ALVIN BRAGG. THAT'S
SENATOR JOHN CORNYN AND SENATOR
JOHN BARRASSO. CORN CORN IN
BARRASSO, AND THROUGH IT ALL,
SEEN AS POTENTIAL SUCCESSORS TO
MCCONNELL DOWN THE LINE AND ALSO
SOME OTHER REACTION THAN SOME
OTHERS WARNING AGAINST A RUSH TO
JUDGMENT THAT COMING FROM
SENATOR LISA MURKOWSKI OF ALASKA
, ONE OF THE SENATORS WHO VOTED
TO CONVICT DONALD TRUMP, IT IS A
SECOND IMPEACHMENT TRIAL, SAYING
THAT SHE IS MONITORING THE
SITUATION. EVERYONE DESERVES A
LEGAL PROCESS FAIR LEGAL
PROCESS, BUT HE SAYS WE
SHOULDN'T VALUE AT THE EVIDENCE
AS IT BECOMES AVAILABLE, SHOWING
THE DIVIDE ONCE AGAIN THAT
EXISTS OVER DONALD TRUMP AMONG
REPUBLICANS ON CAPITOL HILL. ALL
RIGHT, MANU RAJU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. MANU LET'S TURN NOW TO CNN
LEGAL ANALYST CARRIE CORDERO AND
CNN'S SENIOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
ANALYST ANDREW MCCABE. SO CARRIE
WALK US THROUGH WHAT THIS IS
GOING TO LOOK LIKE WHEN TRUMP
APPEARS BEFORE A JUDGE ON
TUESDAY. WELL IT'S A BIG
QUESTION, BECAUSE THIS IS SUCH
AN UNUSUAL AND UNPRECEDENTED
SITUATION. SO I THINK AT THIS
POINT, WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT IT WILL LOOK LIKE BECAUSE
IT HAS THE POTENTIAL, OF COURSE,
TO BE AN ENORMOUS SPECTACLE FOR
THE COUNTRY. IF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT WANTS TO TALK TO MIKE
PROPONENTS IF HE WANTS TO WAVE
TO SUPPORTERS, DEPENDING ON HOW
THE COURT AND THE JUDGE ACTUALLY
HANDLES THE PROCESSING OF HIM.
SO A LOT I THINK DEPENDS
ACTUALLY ON THE SECURITY
PRECAUTIONS THAT GO INTO PLACE
AND THE INTERACTIONS AND THE
PLANNING AND COORDINATION THAT
TAKES PLACE BETWEEN THE SECRET
SERVICE, WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S
PROTECTION AND THE COURT
SECURITY AND THE NEW YORK POLICE
DEPARTMENT, AND THOSE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES REALLY ARE
GOING TO PLAY A BIG ROLE IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE ACTUALLY SEE ON
THE PUBLIC SIDE ON TUESDAY.
YEAH, THERE'S A LOT OF
COORDINATING RIGHT NOW AHEAD OF
TUESDAY. FOR THAT VERY REASON.
ANDREW TRUMP'S LAWYERS ARE
SAYING THEY'RE GOING TO FILE A
MOTION TO DISMISS. DO YOU THINK
THEY HAVE A STRONG CASE TO DO
SO? WELL I'M QUITE SURE THEY
WILL. I'M SURE THERE'LL BE A LOT
OF PRETRIAL MOTIONS THAT WILL
THAT WILL END UP DELAYING ANY
PROGRESS IN IN THIS CASE AS IT
GOES DOWN THE ROAD. I MEAN, I
THINK THERE ARE MANY POTENTIAL
POTENTIALLY CHALLENGING LEGAL
ISSUES BAKED INTO THIS CASE. WE
DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THE D A
HAS CHARGED THE FORMER PRESIDENT
WITH. WE'LL FIND THAT OUT ON
TUESDAY, BUT I THINK MOST AH,
MOST COMMENTATORS BELIEVE THAT
IT'S FOUNDED ON CHARGES
INVOLVING FALSE BUSINESS RECORDS
, WHICH MAY BECOME FELONY
CHARGES IF THE FALSIFICATION IS
DONE WITH THE INTENT TO COVER UP
OR COMMIT A SECOND CRIME. IT'S
WHERE THAT SECOND CRIME COMES
IN. BUT THERE'S ALL SORTS OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
YOU CAN USE AS A SECOND CRIME.
FOR INSTANCE, A VIOLATION OF
FEDERAL CAMPAIGN FINANCE LAW,
WHICH IS ONE THEORY THAT THE
PROSECUTOR MIGHT HAVE USED HERE
, SO NO MATTER WHAT THE
PROSECUTOR IS DONE, I'M
CONFIDENT THAT TRUMP'S LAWYERS
WILL CHALLENGE THE LEGAL AREA
AND THE LEGAL SOUNDNESS OF THIS
CASE AND AN EFFORT TO GET IT
KNOCKED OUT EARLY IN THE
PROCESS, WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE
SUCCESSFUL, WILL HAVE TO SAY WE
KEEP TALKING ABOUT HOW HISTORIC
THIS IS UNPRECEDENTED KERRY AND
IT RAISES THE QUESTION. IF THIS
DOES GO TO TRIAL, HOW WOULD A
FORMER PRESIDENT GET AN
UNTAINTED JURY? I MEAN, EVERYONE
KNOWS WHO HE IS. EVERYONE HAS
VERY STRONG OPINIONS OF HIM
RIGHT, ALTHOUGH THERE ARE CASES
INVOLVING CELEBRITIES AND OTHER
WELL KNOWN PEOPLE, SO THIS
OBVIOUSLY IS HISTORIC, AND IT
WOULD BE HIGHLY UNUSUAL, BUT I
WOULD JUST EMPHASIZE THAT THERE
IS A REAL LONG ROAD BEFORE WE
EVER GET TO A POTENTIAL TRIAL AS
ANDREW WAS DESCRIBING THE FORMER
PRESIDENT IS GOING TO FILE
MOTIONS TO DISMISS THOSE MOTIONS
. I THINK WE'LL HAVE SOME
CREDIBLE ARGUMENTS TO THEM IN
TERMS OF CHALLENGING THE
PROSECUTORS, LEGAL THEORY IN
THIS CASE, AND SO THE MOTIONS
PRACTICE MAY GO ON FOR A PERIOD
OF TIME, EVEN THOUGH RIGHT NOW
PUBLICLY, THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S
LAWYER IS SAYING THAT THERE
NEVER WILL. THERE IS NOT GOING
TO BE A PLEA AND THAT HE WILL
PLEAD NOT GUILTY AS THE CASE
PROGRESSES AND AS DISCOVERY
TAKES PLACE. IT'S A POSSIBILITY
THAT THEY COULD REACH AN
AGREEMENT, FOR EXAMPLE, TO END
UP WITH JUST A MISDEMEANOR IF
THE PREP FORMER PRESIDENT AT
SOME POINT JUST WANTS TO PUT
THIS BEHIND HIM AND MOVE FORWARD
, SO I JUST THINK WE'RE REALLY
LONG WAY AWAY FROM A TRIAL AND
THERE'S A LOT OF LEGAL PROCESS
THAT IS GOING TO TAKE PLACE. IN
THE MEANTIME, WHAT DO YOU THINK,
ANDY? WHAT ARE SOME BIG
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE MOVING
FORWARD, GIVEN THE UNPRECEDENTED
NATURE HERE? WELL PAM IT IT IS
UNPRECEDENTED. AND WE'VE ALL YOU
KNOW, SAID THAT A LOT IN THE
LAST 24 HOURS, BUT I THINK WE
HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT THERE'S A
THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS THAT
HAVE BEEN UNPRECEDENTED ABOUT
THIS. THIS PRESIDENT
UNPRECEDENTED, HAVE ELECTED A
PRESIDENT WHO USED TO RUN A
CHARITY THAT GOT BLOWN UP BY THE
STATE FOR ESSENTIALLY BEING A
FRAUD UNPRECEDENTED TO HAVE A
FORMER PRESIDENT WHOSE COMPANY
THAT HE FOUNDED AND RAN GOT
RECENTLY BEEN CONVICTED OF
MULTIPLE COUNTS OF TAX FRAUD.
IT'S UNPRECEDENTED TO HAVE HAD A
PRESIDENT WHO AH, WHO RALLIED A
, UH, AN ARMED, RIOTOUS MOB TO
ATTACK THE CAPITAL UNPRECEDENTED
OF HOW TO PRESIDENT IMPEACH
TWICE SO WE SHOULD BE PREPARED
FOR UNPRECEDENTED THINGS TO
HAPPEN AROUND DONALD TRUMP. I
THINK IN MANY WAYS AND
INDICTMENT IN THIS CASE, IT WAS
NOT THAT SURPRISIN